- [Narrator] Sleeping on a plane is hard,
especially if you're in an economy seat.
So we asked an expert for advice.
- I'm an Occupational
Therapist, Industrial Designer,
and Certified Professional Ergonomist.
With seated-sleep posture,
not only do you fall into
these awkward postures,
but you're also compressing the vertebrae
and your spine at the different levels.
You have to plan ahead.
- [Narrator] Here's what
a professional ergonomist
recommends for sleeping
in an economy plane seat.
First, you might consider
using the tray table, but.
- The position when using the tray table,
if you're propping up on your forearms,
that awkward positioning,
the contact pressure
against the tray table,
all that's gonna irritate tissue
and sleep just like it would
during your waking hours.
- [Narrator] Contact pressure
happens when soft tissues
are pressed against a
hard surface for too long,
slowing blood flow to your extremities,
and often causing numbness or tingling.
- With soft tissue compression,
you can compromise circulation.
You can impinge nerves,
which can lead to numbness or tingling,
which will often wake people up.
- [Narrator] Then there's your posture.
- [Carla] It's going to be difficult
for you to maintain that posture very long
because you will be
experiencing excessive flexion
at your hips and knees.
Your spine will be rounded.
You'll be putting pressure
through your forearms.
- [Narrator] The solve?
- There are both inflatable
and memory foam cushions
available that start to at least address
some of those risk factors,
such as the contact pressure
against the hard surface of the tray table
by providing a soft surface
for your body to rest.
They can hold your arms
and then it also cradles your
head and neck and your face
in a way that attempts to
at least position your head
and neck in some sort
of a neutral posture.
- [Narrator] But depending on your height,
and how far back the person
in front of you reclines,
the tray table might
not be your best option.
- I think it's probably
gonna serve you well
just for sort of a
short stretch for a nap.
I don't think you'll be getting
the highest quality of sleep
in that position.
- [Narrator] So what about
leaning back in your seat?
- If you have to sleep
in an economy class seat
in a seated position, you are
up against some challenges.
Ideal state, your body
would would prefer to sleep
in a fully-supported lying down position.
Your body already has
to endure weightbearing
and force through your spine, your hips,
your pelvis, your lower extremities.
Whenever it's sleeping, ideally,
it is great if you can steal
a couple degrees of recline
from your seatback just to put your body
in a little bit more of a
supported sleep position.
- [Narrator] Just be
mindful of your neighbors.
You can also adjust your back position.
- Putting just a gentle
cushion behind the seatback
to support the spine is beneficial.
The more head and neck
support you can provide,
the better chance you have at
achieving some restful sleep.
- [Narrator] And here's
where a travel pillow
comes in handy.
- A lot of these supports
are not all created equal.
There are the tried and
true U-shaped neck pillows.
You wanna keep your head and
neck as neutral as possible
against the unfortunate barrier of gravity
and upright positioning.
A lot of the ones that I
like wrap around the neck
and have a support just so
they don't shift during sleep.
They can sort of provide
full neck support,
so not just forward flexion,
but lateral flexion, even some extension.
It can hold your head
in like a comfortable,
yet supported position for sleep.
- [Narrator] And if you
don't have a pillow,
as a last resort.
- You can try to make do
with layers of clothing.
I think the thesis here
is that if you are in a
scenario where you have to sleep
or you're flying during evening hours,
you have to plan ahead.
- [Narrator] Besides pillows and posture,
there are a few other helpful
tips for sleeping on planes.
- You might think about
limiting light exposure
with an eye mask,
or having layers or a
blanket for thermal comfort,
noise-canceling headphones
just to limit some of the
auditory stimulation on a plane.
- [Narrator] When it comes
to picking between the aisle,
middle, and window seats,
there isn't one best option for everyone.
- It's gonna be a bit subjective
in terms of what people
find most comfortable
sleeping on an airplane.
- [Narrator] If you
need to use the bathroom
or stretch frequently, the
aisle might be your best option,
but it also means you'll be woken up
every time your seatmates
need to get out as well.
- I think if you can
avoid the middle seat,
that's probably the best advice.
- [Narrator] And while the
window seat can provide support,
just make sure to add a pillow
or piece of clothing as a cushion.
Importantly, flyers should find a position
that allows them to move around a bit
while they sleep, like
they normally would in bed.
- The body is built to be dynamic,
and your body needs those movement breaks
in order to lubricate joints,
to release muscle tension,
to mitigate strain.
- [Narrator] But for those people
who still really can't snooze mid-flight.
- It's always worth it to get an upgrade.
(bright music)